welcome to metaphysical milkshake folks
my name is rain wilson i am one of the
hosts and my name is rosa aslan i am the
other host and rain people might not
know this about you but you're white
yes yes just i just want to make sure
like you know you you self-identify i
couldn't be i couldn't be whiter my
heritage
isn't norwegian
dutch
and english
if you were any whiter you'd be
translucent
is that a fair statement yeah i think
that is a fair that is a fair state
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
and yet and yet my friend rayne wilson
uh people know this about you if they
don't they should you do a lot
of good work around the world one of the
many issues that you're most passionate
about is education particularly girls
education particularly girls education
in in very very poor places shall we say
primarily non-white
uh places am i am i still sure am i
still on the right track here
yeah yeah sure but you know you have to
be careful when you have that
conversation because you immediately can
go to like white saviorism like oh
here's the wealthy white guy going into
the
poor environment and
feeling sorry for all the all the people
of color and and bestowing their wealth
and their knowledge onto the deserving
it is a minefield it is it is a it's a
minefield so we you know we do this work
in haiti
and we certainly talk about it we raise
money for it at le day haiti but we
swiftly after founding the organization
have made it haitian run
and organized with a staff of about 50
haitians working on these issues we just
advise from the board and we try and
raise money but it's a it's a minefield
it's it's very
it's very tricky and um
yeah we well us white people man
don't get me started but what do you
what do you got to say about this well
look i mean it looks like you got
something to say
i mean
this idea of the white savior it's not
as clear-cut as uh i think people
make it seem sometimes i mean look it
there's no question there's no denying
the fact that there are some regions in
the world africa middle east haiti where
you do a lot of your work that have you
know long served as a kind of backdrop
for all these like white fantasies of
like heroism
and often often times
that's done under this sort of banner of
like making a difference right i'm out
there making a difference but in reality
what i'm really doing is like having a
great adventure
or
making up for my my uh you know wealth
in some way by like
going out into the world and and giving
uh you know
whatever help and freedom you know to to
you know the these dark and savage lands
and certainly
i mean you and i are both in hollywood
certainly hollywood has definitely
played its part in perpetuating that the
myth of the white savior like basically
it's like an entire industry
right of uh of uh you know movies about
well-intentioned kind-hearted white
people
who saves the poor
needy person
of color and like we could go on forever
naming movies
like that right
but here's the problem
okay
what happens when
the person doing the saving
is in fact white
you know what i'm saying
yeah constance wu has this great quote
about the film the great wall do you
remember the great wall
matt damon uh that's matt damon with a
ponytail fighting dragons in medieval
china yeah that's the one that's the one
uh constant wu said this whole thing
where she said
uh are heroes meaning chinese heroes our
heroes don't look like matt damon
which is a hundred percent true
but
what happens when the hero does look
like matt damon like how are we supposed
to respond to a genuine hero
when that person
happens to be white
well this brings up a lot of things i
mean first of all
the reason that that 250 million dollar
epic was greenlit was because they had a
star of matt damon's magnitude in the
lead role and there's not any chinese
stars
that can command that kind of uh box
office where people are willing to
spread that kind of money so
you know there's kind of
chicken and egg kind of thing going on
there also it's interesting because i've
for a long time been trying to get this
project going about this um
civil rights pioneer named stetson
kennedy who was a white guy who
infiltrated the clan
and
wrote about it from the inside and
actually brought the story of the clan
to the superman radio hour and got the
writers of superman to have superman
battle the clan no it's a fantastic
story it's uh unbelievable but
it's about racism and it's about a white
guy and he's a hero and there were some
white heroes in the battle of civil
rights in fighting racism
but we've heard a lot of their stories
and we're at a time right now where
telling this story is very very
difficult because you know stetson kenny
had a lot of black friends and allies
but this is kind of a white guy doing
anti-racism work
and
you know that we've we've had trouble
moving the project forward because it's
and and maybe we should have trouble
moving that project forward i don't know
well so this is obviously a topic that
i'm very interested in and
i have a friend
a colleague jyoti tottem who is the
deputy op-ed editor at the new york
times a brilliant journalist and she has
written a book called the sisters of
makama which is the story of a group of
nuns they're like between the year ages
like 15 and 50 or something like that
who travel to india right after
partition
to essentially
establish a hospital a teaching hospital
and to train
uh nurses and it's such a fascinating
story and they've done such amazing work
there but
as you can imagine the story of a bunch
of white women who go
to india with they don't know anything
about indian politics or culture they
don't speak the language who are there
to quote unquote
save the population brings up a lot of
these very very tricky subjects so i'm
really fascinated to talk about you know
the whole white savior uh issue with
jyoti but i figured that this would be
uh you know for obvious reasons a good
episode to not invite you to to you know
as the white person i'm gonna sit this
one out
i'm gonna sit you just quietly sit in
the corner
well you know what while the brown
people talk about white saviors
i'm gonna just listen and learn
so without further ado let's bring on
jyoti tottem to the milkshake
jody thank you so much for joining i was
gonna say us on metaphysical milkshake
but it's just me just lowly old me well
that's all right i'm excited to be here
i mean i know that as a gigantic office
fan that's why you were going to do this
podcast anyway so it must be quite quite
a disappointment but i'm not
disappointed i am thrilled
to have you here i love this book
sisters of makama here it is
oh thank you we're going to talk a lot
about this book but it the story for
people who are unfamiliar with it it's a
story of these six nuns from kentucky of
all places who travel to uh
post-partition india
um to set up this hospital i guess
primarily to treat leprosy but you know
become become sort of a general uh
hospital in the state of bihar and also
to train
nurses and first off you know before we
kind of get into
the book itself and talk about these
incredible women and and what they've
done and their legacy
why don't we set the scene um for a
minute for for those of us who have yet
to see disney's miss marvel
if you i've heard it teaches everything
you wanted to know about participation
i mean i feel kind of good because i
haven't seen it yet and i feel like it's
you know brown people on tv and so i'm
therefore obligated yeah my kids are a
huge huge miss marvel i'm good i'm gonna
watch it everybody at disney please
don't send me emails i am gonna watch it
i'm very excited to watch it i'm sure
it's fantastic i love the fact that it
is teaching
not just kids honestly i had a
conversation with like a 40 year old man
the other day who watched it and he was
like i had no idea about
the history of india and pakistan and
partition and i was like are you joking
are you kidding me but all right fine
fine
tv teaching people about history so but
for those of us who are not caught up on
miss marvel can you give us a little bit
of the background here set the scene of
exactly what was happening in india
post-partition and particularly in bihar
and in uh where the with the nuns set up
yeah and thank you for asking me this
question because you know when i saw the
twitter commentary about like what i
never heard about partitioning right it
was like
in fact i wrote an entire book
about this there you go this is this is
my chance to to tell you um if you're
wondering like did americans have
anything to do with partition well in
fact they did how about that um
so that's sort of um
that's sort of where it starts i mean we
actually had to start
at the end of world war ii because in
fact um you know there's been a lot of
history written about that period night
you know
the
the years leading up to world war ii the
war itself
which you know obviously involved um so
many countries including india which you
know people don't know
and
so actually that decision about what
india was going to do in world war ii
when it was still a colonial um holding
of the uk that was an incredibly
important decision because
the british and the british army
needed india like they needed indian
soldiers they needed
india to supply this like massive army
that was fighting all over the world so
um
you know it's it's a strange situation
in a sense like
you're basically colonizing these people
and then asking them to fight on your
behalf right for some other people's
freedom
right so you can see that this was
not an easy sell for a lot of
indians i mean there were and this was a
a deep and divisive debate within the
indian
independence movement i mean if you read
some of the the history of that period
it's really kind of fascinating um this
this debate back and forth you know
there were um
obviously like factions who didn't agree
with ultimately the the indian national
congress decided like okay
we will
join the fight
but they they made it like
not quite explicitly but basically a
condition that but when this war is over
we're out of here like you you know
we we are expecting that india will be
free and the british will leave
so i mean that's that's a an oversimply
simplification of like many years of
intense political debate and sort of
jockeying over this issue but
ultimately like that's that's basically
what happened you know um the war ended
and soon after the war ended
the british started making moves
uh to both
leave india like meaning you know remove
all the america all the the british
troops and american troops were there as
well they were starting to leave india
um and they were starting this process
of
okay fine you know
thank you for fighting in the war
we're leaving now the british
left
uh without a very clear plan and the
worst part of it was
there wasn't a really clear political
plan about
who was going to be in charge of this
massive
population this massive territory when
they left because there was no div no
consensus about who would be in charge
there was also no agreement about
well exactly what kind of country is
india going to be is it you know simply
this like huge
multi-religious multi-ethnic
multicultural
country or is it
one country for hindus another country
for muslims
so
again
none of those questions were really
fully answered other than to draw a line
on a map
you know tell
between you know parts that were mostly
majority hindu and
mostly majority
muslim and say okay that's it you know
find you you know good luck we're
leaving find your places
um
and we're out of here
so partition the trauma of partition is
basically those
months
before independence in 1947
and
after immediately after independence
when
people were like okay we are very
excited to be independent
thank you for leaving british empire
but
now it's kind of a huge huge mess that
was the
chaos of partition yeah possibly
anywhere between 10 and 20 million
displaced
people
deaths ranging from anywhere in the
hundreds of thousands to maybe 2 million
um just you know absolute
chaos
um as what you have is the largest mass
migration in the history of the world
that's right
and now folks a little word from our
sponsor
better help
you know
wellness
mental wellness self-care is so
important for all of us it's especially
important for me
i wake up every morning i have my kind
of devotional period which is meditation
and some prayer
um i do a little journaling sometimes of
course i have my weekly therapy these
are the things that keep me grounded
that keep me
kind of aligned with my life's mission
and purpose with a little bit of
serenity thrown in
you know it's funny like even to this
day there's still a weird stigma about
getting therapy which just doesn't make
any sense at all like you like you
rightly said you know we are all dealing
with a world on fire and listen
it helps to have someone to talk to
about all that stuff and what's great is
that better help
is an online therapy service it offers
video phone and even live chat only
therapy sessions so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you don't need to go sit in a a dusty
office you know in a waiting room with a
bunch of other patients this is very
private it's all about you
and the things that you need to get off
your chest and by the way it's also much
more affordable than in-person therapy
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours so our listeners get 10
percent off their first month at
betterhelp.com milkshake that's better
he lp.com
slash milkshake give it a try
uh rain um i have heard i've heard it
said that there's this thing that um
some people have and it's called um
what is it fun
is that is that a
is that a thing
yeah yeah fun is that fun is the thing
it's really important it's a it's
actually an important part of our
self-care you know a lot of us are
burned out overworked stressed out fun
is important reza and i gotta bring some
fun into your life and apparently people
have fun during something called free
time
am i saying that right free yeah time
well i i i i neither have free time nor
do i have fun
so right i'm not sure about this but
what i do know
is that if i did have some free time
and if i were a person who had fun
well then best fiends would be what i
would spend my time doing my friend best
fiends oh my god it's so much fun i love
it it is an adorable
puzzle adventure game and you're not
gonna be able to put it down so much fun
reza
i just recently
i have not stopped on best fiends since
i first downloaded the app i'm on level
125
called riptides
all of my little fiends
you know i've been cultivating growing
grooming for battle i've brought them in
to fight those evil nasty slugs on a
boat it was awesome
best fiends is a free to download mobile
puzzle game with thousands of exciting
levels for new adventures and challenges
every single time you play listeners
listen you've earned your fun time so go
to the app store or or google play to
download best fiends for free plus earn
even more with five dollars worth of
in-game rewards when you reach level
five
that's friends
without the r
best fiends
and
in the into the into this chaotic
situation
steps the six nuns
from kentucky they were between i guess
20 and 50 years old
they walk into
um this country they don't speak any
hindi obviously i imagine they don't
really have any clue about the culture
or
um the religion probably know very
little about the politics or anything
else that's going on and just kind of
show up what did they find when they
when they arrived in bihar yeah so that
that is exactly what the situation was
so like at that same time that you know
1946 when
you know really like nobody like no one
knows what's going to happen they get
this letter saying please can you come
and help with this hospital
and
who sent the letter just
it was the jesuits
jesuits who were already working in this
part of bihar the state of northern
india
and they had been trying to set up a
hospital for years but again partly
because of that uncertainty and also
partly because
that the jesuit mission was like one guy
who had no medical skills or training or
at all
he really was not equipped to set up a
hospital um but he had promised that and
you know by 1946 like the need for it
especially as people started you know
moving um there were refugees everywhere
it became extreme and he and he was sort
of like a last-ditch effort like maybe
i can find some help he was an american
maybe i can sort of um you know the
archdiocese can call on some some people
in america maybe someone will help
and
these women said yes yes they like they
decided to say yes and why they say yes
is also a very interesting question but
i mean that is basically this the
situation that they were coming into on
that note of why did they say yes i mean
the sisters of charity that's who they
were the sisters of charity
um as nazareth of nazareth um
you know this is kind of their jam isn't
it like that's kind of what the sisters
of charity were meant
uh to to do is to like show up in the
middle of nowhere because a jesuit
priest was like please help
what can you tell us about kind of the
this congregation this this um
uh this group of sisters and kind of
what what
compelled them
to actually step into this
uh truly unfamiliar situation yeah
so it's true like this is the kind of
thing that they did you know they were
kind of like
you know war disease
bring it on like they had done this at
many points in their history like they
you know they've been around in kentucky
since um
the early 1800s
they had served as nurses during the
civil war the spanish-american war i
mean really like that was their thing um
i mean there was one of one of their um
sisters
uh like you know died on the battlefield
in the civil war and was like given a
you know
uh
burial with like both union and
confederate troops because like they
respected them so much um
but you know it's interesting by the
1930s um you know they've been around a
while they had become
much more established
in kentucky and they've kind of lost
some of that you know they they were
sort of like oh we're running our
schools and hospitals
um you know actually like we're we're
gonna sort of stay at home like you know
that was kind of the
yeah they had become less adventurous
and they had become an order who sort of
stayed and like
did you know good works closer to home
in kentucky but you know what happened
in world war ii
when so many women so many nurses
american women were going all over the
world to to sort of to serve in the war
effort
and you know young like that was
considered a very
i mean incredibly difficult but that was
glamorous work like that was what you
did if you know if you were sort of a
woman with
ideas and ambition and wanted to see the
world like you became a nurse and you
you did that and so that the young
sisters
in this order they wanted to do that as
well but their superiors
they actually said no like fdr
you know asked them like can you please
serve overseas and we said they said no
actually
wait we can't like unless it's a real
emergency like we're going to stay at
home oh this is a real emergency like
world war
you know otherwise we're going to stay
home anyway yes so
you know by the i mean frankly like the
the sisters were were disappointed and
um
one of them sort of
like there there was a visiting jesuit
who was going from the us to india
um at the end of 1945 the war had just
ended and she literally told him like
you know what if you ever hear of an
opportunity for us to go abroad please
tell us
because like we desperately like want we
want to do what you're doing like you're
going out into the world and having
adventures that's what we want to do and
that's exactly what happened then
you know he went to india he heard about
you know this place where they needed
nurses
and he you know and they said like hey
what about those women like
they're really smart they know how to
run hospitals like they want to go
abroad let's ask them
and so that's what happened like they
you know they had that opportunity that
they didn't have in world war ii
and they said yes absolutely we're there
they were given i mean these young women
like they were given
weeks like they you know their superiors
told them okay now that we're going
you've got like three weeks
go home to your families
say goodbye
and assume that you you may never see
them again
right because that's basically what
missionary life was like at that time
i'm really glad that you brought up the
the issue about sort of women in the
role that women assumed you know uh
in that second world war because in a
lot of ways this story
has this very
unexpected feminist streak to it and you
even talk about these nuns as trying to
carve out a a new kind of role
as women in the church right that this
was
obviously a missionary enterprise yes
and we'll talk about that and obviously
this was an uh a a an enterprise of
mercy right that they were there to do
good to help and
you know as much as they could but at
the same time they also
i feel like they were fairly conscious
of the fact that their actions
in leaving kentucky going to to india um
was sort of very deliberately meant to
create this kind of different
position a different understanding of
the role that women could play
in what is
i don't need to tell anyone a very
patriarchal
church can you talk about that aspect of
this story these women as
i i don't want to use the term feminist
icon because that doesn't make any sense
but but you know what i'm trying to say
here yeah exactly i mean this was
something that i felt was sort of
a subtext through so many of
the letters that they would write home
about you know sort of describing what
they were doing or
um
describing like what it was like to
actually do that work because you know
yes of course they're missionaries
they're devout
catholic women in a catholic religious
community
but they also were very aware of the
fact that there were things that they
could do as missionaries
that they could not do if they stayed
at home
and that was very very appealing to
certain kinds of women in fact
um you know i won't get into like the
details of canon law but you know until
like
the late 1930s if you were
if you were a catholic nun you couldn't
if you stayed in the united states
you could be a nurse but you couldn't be
a doctor but if you became a missionary
you were allowed to be a doctor which is
of course in a hospital setting you know
a much more powerful prestigious kind of
thing so i mean literally there were
things that you couldn't do
and even when they were there you know
like this was again like they're coming
from one patriarchal system to another
india was
um just as you know just like
was no different in that sense from uh
the united states and they you know they
were running that hospital by themselves
i mean the jesuits might have invited
them but pretty much as soon as they got
there
they
you know very kind of delicately
distanced themselves and said you know
what thank you for setting this up but
we're gonna make the decisions on our
own now you know what like i know you
want us to help you with your the school
you're already running but actually
we're gonna start our own school like
we're gonna do
our own thing um i mean it was just
everything like they they in the first
few months like they learned hindi they
learned the trains they sort of figured
out the political
ins and outs of like what is going on in
this sort of learning the trains way
harder than learning hindi
i think that's about right yeah i think
that's about right so again everything
they were doing was
you know taking advantage of that space
that they had because they were
missionaries and they were not you know
as closely tied to um what they call the
mother house like the sort of central
headquarters that you know they would
just sort of do things and kind of let
let people know later like you know when
they decided you know what we need
bicycles to get around oh but the order
like that wasn't really allowed like
well they just kind of did it anyway and
i told them later
like oh by the way i mean they changed
their
their habits you know like they started
there in like very traditional like
heavy wool and cotton full-length
habits and these complicated bonnets
and that was just like not practical at
all and they were you know without
really asking they were like you know
what we're just gonna change this like
wait you know they were wearing even
um you know sort of regular clothes
well before that became
a thing after vatican ii so
yeah they kind of carved out this space
to be much more independent than they
would have been if they'd stayed at home
hey uh reza
yeah do you remember on the office when
they had the finer things club oh do i
finer things so many of us enjoy these
finer things
like oscar did and toby and pam
and so many of us settle for blah coffee
every day but with trade coffee
you can start every morning with
something special
okay so we want to tell you about trade
coffee it's a coffee subscription
service it's unlike anything you've
tried before they partner with top
independent roasters to freshly roast
and send the best coffees in the country
direct to your home on your preferred
schedule
hey rayne how was the the coffee on the
set of the office not not very good no
it was not good well it's definitely not
as good a trade coffee i'll tell you
that right now
nice nice segue and that's because your
trade experience can be as simple or
sophisticated as you want you can
quickly select from curated collections
by roast flavor profile brewing method
and more also their team of experts do
all the work for you they taste test
hundreds of coffees from across the u.s
every month and then they end up
curating about 450 exceptional coffees
that make the cut or if you're a
sophisticated coffee drinker like i am
and you want something curated just for
you then you just take a couple of
minutes and you complete this really fun
trade coffee
quiz
so trade is the easiest way to get your
very best tasting coffee delivered fresh
when you need it you got nothing to lose
because trade guarantees you will love
your first bag if not they'll work with
you to replace it for free
so
if you want to support small business
and brew the best cup of coffee you've
ever made at home it's time to try trade
coffee
right now trade is offering our
listeners a total of dollars off your
first order plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com
milkshake that's
drinktrade.com milkshake for thirty
dollars off your subscription to the
best coffees in the world
it's really extraordinary they they
arrive
you know
to this region that is just absolutely
riddled by violence it's
there's incredible destitution on the
streets
they're given this large unheated
structure there's no electricity there's
no running water
there's no hospital beds it's a hospital
without any beds that's kind of
problematic
uh there's no medicine by the way
there's like no nurses there's no staff
it's basically just like the shell
and they're kind of told good luck and
then this kind of incredible
transformation that happens with these
women and
and the work that they do i mean the
story itself is is extraordinary
and what i love about it is that you
have this incredibly intimate personal
connection to it
uh you've said you've obviously
mentioned this a thousand times but your
own mom
was actually one of the nurses
who was trained
um at this hospital in the 60s can you
talk a little bit about sort of how the
story of these nuns kind of entered your
consciousness and how that
sort of led to this place where you
decided that you know you were going to
write this book i know the book took a
very very long time yeah it's um
so you know as you mentioned the
hospital when it started had you know
had nothing and not even nurses so they
the nuns had to train their own nurses
like they found women local women who
wanted to be nurses set up a nursing
school
and one of the
indian women who trained to be
a nurse at nazareth hospital is uh is my
mother she was there in the early 1960s
how old was she at the time so she was
15 when she left home to become
a nurse uh the same age that my daughter
is now i still like it's hard to believe
right get over that yeah
you know this is like this place and
that experience of um
leaving home um to study nursing it was
something that you know in a sense like
my mother took for granted it was just
something she did a long time ago so
you know by the time i was a teenager
and you know you start to ask questions
like so you know
how did we
come to the united states you know i was
born in india although i grew up um in
the united states
uh like how did we get here like why did
like why did you leave india you know
all these questions that a lot of um
immigrant parents hear from
from their kids
so you know the story that she would
tell me was
not it was she was like well you know i
wanted to be like i left home i was a
nurse nurses could come here
you know i had studied nursing with
these american
women from kentucky
in bihar and
you know she would just sort of she
would talk about
how strict they were that you know it
was
that it was hard work and and all of
that but i think like a lot of immigrant
parents do she would sort of
you know skip over the hard parts and
kind of skip to and then we came here
and everything is great in america
and
we lived happily ever after and here we
are so um
you know when you're growing up uh i'm
sure like everybody has these kind of
family stories that
you know they're a little bit
you know either bizarre or unusual or
don't totally make sense or you know you
don't really know the full story but you
kind of think oh well whatever like it's
they're just my parents you know
like what whatever whatever that is so
you know when i became when i was older
and went to india as a journalist and
really spent some time
in that particular part of india which
really is one of the most difficult
parts of india to live in i mean
i mean you go to delhi or bombay and
tell someone you're going to be har and
the
the first thing they'll usually ask you
is like why why would you go there and
like why
you know
like
why would you go there by choice
um it's it's really like not um i mean
there are beautiful parts of it it's and
it has a long and rich history but it's
life is it
you know it's hard to deny it's very
very difficult there so
um
so
that's when i really started to kind of
peel back the layers and try to figure
out well
how like why was this nursing school in
this
you know this out of the way place like
why did these american women come here
of all places and how did my mother get
there so that is really where the book
started with the journey asking those
questions
you know it's uh i was talking about
the not just the incredible
transformation that these um nuns
underwent themselves but
the
incredible work that they end up doing
um in bihar and
and the legacy that they have you know
that this the hospital is still open
people do i mean right it's still there
oh yeah yeah still there it's still
there they were treating people i mean
it's it's different than what it was
it's mostly like primary care now
because there are other hospitals but
man when covid hit india
they needed that hospital it was really
um
it was tough as much as we have to
contend with the fact that these
missionaries
especially these you know sisters of
mercy did such incredible good i mean
they
they've done so much
uh positive work um in
caring for
the the people and and um helping
develop this this area
it it's still hard to grapple with the
fact that they were missionaries and
that fundamentally
their motivation was to you know convert
the heathen population
to christ very much the exact same goal
of the colonialists who had just fled
you know and i think what what it does
is
it forces us to kind of really grapple
with
the uncomfortable grayness of this kind
of missionary work you are
absolutely clear about the legacy of
these sisters uh
and what they accomplished um i love
this line that you you have about their
hospital where you say every person who
crossed its threshold was entitled to an
equal dignity this alone was a radical
idea and a place where the bodies of
indian men women and children had been
quite literally starved in the service
of empire
and and you know i look at the the
subtitle the pioneering woman who
brought hope and healing to india
but they're white christians
so
like if i were to change that subtitle
to the white women the white christian
women who brought hope and healing to
india you know where i'm going with this
question
right
which is that
these kinds of stories regardless of how
heroic the figures are almost
immediately nowadays lend themselves to
the criticism
of white saviorism right oh geez this is
just another white savior story oh here
these white these white women of
privilege coming to india in the guise
of you know doing good but in reality
you know uh they're sort of
it's it's a very it's a self-serving
project right that it's about it's about
validating their privilege by engaging
in some big emotional experience in a
dark and foreign land i'm sure you've
heard people say this what what's your
response to that um
that critique yeah i think it's it's an
important question to ask i mean as a
writer or like anyone who's interested
in
these stories i mean there is i think
something
that's irresistible about
the idea of you know just someone going
on an adventure anywhere right and but
you're right like these are white women
who had
a particular reason for going like a
particular opportunity to go
so
but the way i think about it is
it's
it's of course like up to me you know as
a thinking person and you know
as uh a brown person you know to really
think about this
but it wasn't only up to me because in
fact
the
these american women in the story
they were confronted with this
by
indian women
like as pretty much as soon as they got
there right like the the women who they
encountered
sort of
like they did that work like they pushed
back against
um you know the notion like the
sort of offensive notions that they had
i mean in their own ways like they did
that and they
they sort of forced
the mission the hospital the order
itself
to examine these questions for
themselves like and that's
actually like the the second half of the
book is well okay yes
these white women set up the hospital
it's an amazing project but then what
happens when they
bring indian women into the community
as nurses and nuns and
you know frankly like they can't do this
work without them
so you know those indian women like
they're not just sitting there sort of
you know
blindly doing whatever um
they're told like
in many ways big and small like they
challenged
the notions that these women had and the
order is different today because the
hospital is different today because of
it um
so you know i guess the way i answer
that question is like
it's it's not simply up to me to
challenge like it's
they have been challenged all along the
way and that is actually part of the
story yeah i'm really glad you brought
that up because i think look there's a
lot of truth to this the white savior
trope obviously and i mean there's it's
just a fact that there has been a very
real and undeniable pattern of you know
people in these you know less developed
parts of the world particularly south
asia middle east africa who have been
widely viewed as passive recipients
of like
the benevolence of white people
right um
it that's undeniable right it's
undeniable that this region has served
as a backdrop for
um white fantasies of heroism
we've seen that you know throughout
history
but i just i wonder if we've gone a
little too far with this white savior
trope because
there's no question that we need to shed
you know some light on the problem of
white privilege
um but i think
doing so can sometimes
a
uh dismiss the very real contributions
you know of white people who gave up
everything who sacrificed sometimes
their lives uh to do what they thought
was you know
good work whether it's you know
motivated by their religion or their
politics or what have you but i also
worry if like nowadays
this kind of white savior
uh critique has actually dissuaded
um
you know some people of privilege
to
actually
you know
meet the obligations that they would
have in
intervening in humanitarian disasters
around the world going out and actually
spending their money you know that they
that they have made and and trying to
change the world in in some sense for
the better um
so i i don't know i to me i'm conflicted
i i really really get it i understand
the critique but i'm i also i don't know
it makes me prickle just a little bit
when i hear it well i guess the way i
think about it is
you know if the answer if the sort of
white savior critique
if the conclusion to draw from that is
you know well no one should ever
anywhere outside of the you know their
own community to try to do anything
because
you know oh well that's just you and
your white savior complex
i think that is i'm not really sure
if that
accomplishes much in the world um but
what i would say is like yes you should
you know if you are um
a privileged person going
out and trying to help in the world
using your privilege to do that
i do think that it behooves you to
kind of think about you know
these questions and think about like
well is there a way for me
to do this work
and not
you know not just kind of
um
do whatever i want just because like
well this is this is good work you
should just be grateful because you know
frankly it's hard work to kind of
uh
allow
the people that you're helping to truly
you know
be a part of that work you know and and
this is definitely like what the
hospital found you know
if they were
not going to simply impose themselves
that meant oh you have to like give up
some power you have to
bring indian women into the leadership
of your institution which is what they
did it means that
you have to learn the local language
it's you don't like expect people to
just everyone to speak english that's
that's up to you you have to do that
hard work you know you have to learn
um the place that you're going in you
have to adapt
your
your institution you know your
organization your own work to what is
actually needed and
um i think that's the step that a lot of
people never take yeah and actually this
is kind of
one of the things that i loved so much
about the story of these nuns
um and yes i mean look i think i i agree
with you and i do think that the the
i would go so far as to say that the
myth of the white savior
um
can itself sometimes become a racist
trope
you know not just in the sense that it
discourages people of means from
engaging in the very real
problems that that plague the world but
also in the idea that like the very act
of wanting to do so is necessarily a
kind of
um
uh
expression of white dominance you know
there's a lot that i that i have a
problem with but the thing that i
really am fascinated by is the way in
which stories like this that sometimes
get immediately dismissed by you know
unthinking though well-intentioned
people
as a story of a white savior
miss
the point because to me
i feel like
a lot of these stories are
mischaracterized
as white savior tropes when in reality
what we really find when we when we
really dig down into these stories is
that it's it's not that it's white
people
necessarily coming to save the other
it's often white people
who are themselves saved
by the
encounter with
the other the the engagement with the
foreign indigenous communities you you
brought up the the point that you know
these nuns
they didn't know what the hell they were
doing
and they really had to
not just bring in help but rely on that
help and change become different people
like in a sense
you know they came there for the
salvation of india and in
reality they found sort of their own
salvation
right so
so many of these stories is it kind of
flips the white savior trope on its head
and in reality
it's the white person who is transformed
and quote unquote
saved when
removed from his or her you know comfort
uh and thrust into
these often unfamiliar situations
motivated by nothing but just kind of a
sense of you know like a desire to do
something meaningful
yeah i think the
the part of the white savior narrative
that i
find to be
a problem is
i think when it um
when it sort of ignores the agency of
the people whom
like you know missionaries or
volunteer you know whoever it is you're
talking about like when it ignores that
like you know the people who they're
working with whom they're helping like
they also have ideas about what's going
on like they are also sort of
participating in this project and
working on it and shaping it and
changing it and you know they're not
simply just kind of standing there
a lot you know
allowing themselves to be quote unquote
saved so i i think you know and for me
also like that was frankly um the
hardest part of
the work and and the research was you
know i i couldn't just tell the story of
the american women like if i had done
that it like it truly would have been
like simply another like white savior
story so
frankly you know it it took a lot
of a lot of effort to find
like find people like find documents
find you know archival records letters
track people down and like all kinds of
remote places
so that i
could actually hear like well what was
it like
for you as the indian women who were
involved in this
because i wanted that to be an useful
part of the story
yeah no and and it really is and it's
wonderful
i'm curious how do you think you know
mukama itself changed as a result of
the sisters presence or or maybe there's
a better way to put this like how did
their presence
um eventually become sort of part of the
community fabric of this region in india
so
it's it's a remarkable thing to visit
now the last time i was there i mean
this is a hospital in again
you know a small town a very you know
that's basically run by a few very
powerful uppercased
families uppercast men
and right in the middle of it is
this hospital which is not only
you know a strong and
you know an important sort of
institution that's run by
a minority a religious minority in india
which is a very difficult thing right
now
but it is completely run by women yeah
and there are just so few places like
that
in a town like this in india so
that in itself like just their presence
is a reminder of you know what's
possible
and it's really become sort of a magnet
for
i mean now it's it's really not about
you know i mean there are no american
women who work there anymore um you know
it's really very much run by indian
women
but now i mean the young women who are
coming there
are from
uh
the indigenous communities of india you
know there are sort of
indian women who
generally are coming from more educated
communities who are
running it like right now they're the
sort of leadership level but the women
who are coming up
are from indigenous communities which
are again like they're layers and layers
of
oppression in a place like india and i
feel like it's sort of
you know you see how things change i
mean and there are issues there like oh
well
you know these are more privileged
indian women you know kind of
working with um
less privileged indian women like there
are issues there but again this is a
place that's kind of growing and
changing all the time yeah it's so it's
such a fascinating story um not just
because you know these these nuns
themselves are so interesting and all
their different personalities and and
the you know the transformation that
they undergo but also because the book
itself uses their and their experiences
to tell this fascinating
history of partition um
that i still it boggles the mind that
people don't know like grown-ups don't
know this history still boggles my mind
but fine and just the sort of the
feminist movement and and the role of
missionaries in india it's a it's an
absolutely delightful and such a fun
book to read um it's called sisters of
makama
um and jyoti totem i'm so grateful for
you to join us on metaphysical milkshake
thank you for this conversation jody
totem thank you for joining us it's
called the sisters of makama it's
available now at all bookstores i'm
really grateful for the time
so uh there you go rain uh
wow did that make you feel uncomfortable
just slightly no no no not at all i mean
it's i got a lot out of it it's
fascinating it's complicated it's
nuanced
it's incendiary it's an important
conversation for us to be happening i'll
tell you one thing that that's really
interesting you know this when we were
talking about how
it is often the case that the white
savior is the one who ends up getting
saved that oftentimes the the sort of
the the privileged you know
white man who goes into whatever the
foreign land in order to like bestow the
gift
of whiteness
upon them
more often than not what happens is that
they are the ones who receive the gift
of the indigenous culture they are the
ones who are often transformed they're
the ones who get saved you know what i'm
saying but that's something that you
could probably relate to well
listen um the work that we've done in
haiti has been truly transformative for
my wife and i
uh in so many ways um
and of course we came in with that kind
of like
white american can do idealism of like
hey we can just do this and x y and z
and set up a school here and teach this
and and of course nothing went according
to plan and
we were humbled by our own um
arrogance as well and uh but it has been
uh truly a pleasure and an honor to
be
[Music]
hiring working with haitians learning
from them
uh because who better knows the needs of
their country uh than the haitians
themselves so
um
it's really uh really putting to bed
once and for all that
uh we uh white americans have the
answers and know the best way and are
dispersing that throughout the world um
as the british and the french and and
the dutch and everyone else were doing
in centuries previous um it's really
time to put put that to bed because that
has had devastating consequences but
you know being white doesn't mean you
shouldn't try to you shouldn't stop
but you know being white doesn't mean
you should stop trying to help people
because it can help them and transform
yourself
and
um but my favorite story around this is
kung fu where of course other than the
fact that david carradine was white and
should have been chinese had he been
played by the original idea which was
bruce lee
kung fu with the chinese man
coming to the old west teaching the
americans about peace love and the
dharma
um
and with a little martial arts thrown in
that's a beautiful story
yeah
look it's a lot more complicated than i
think uh
it sounds on its surface and i think
that was what the conversation really
brought out what do you guys think
milkshakers tell us uh what are your
thoughts about the whole white savior
trope it's very easy to get in touch
with us obviously you can find us on
social media at reza aslan and rayne
wilson and on twitter at metamilkpodcast
we're on instagram at metaphysical
milkshake
what's your thoughts on the white savior
trope has the white savior trope itself
become a kind of racist
trope uh let us know uh you can also
remember to follow rate and review
metaphysical milkshake on apple podcasts
or wherever else you listen to podcasts
and indeed if you do
review us on apple podcasts all you got
to do is email us a screenshot of that
review you can email it to metaphysical
cast media.com that's cast with a k
and if you do that the first five people
will get a copy of sisters of mukama
this
fascinating story of these
half dozen nuns and you can of course
also subscribe to the metaphysical
milkshake youtube channel and watch our
full episodes every week and uh you know
we love you guys let's i can't wait to
read that book i really can't and i
think you're a little biased because you
just wrote a book about a white guy who
traveled all the way to iran
to go
take part in the iranian revolution at
the turn of the century that's right
can't wait to read all of these
delicious white savior stories coming
soon white saviors are all the rage
right now so hot so trendy um thanks for
listening everybody thanks for that
great interview reza all right take care
everyone metaphysical milkshake is
executive produced by rayne wilson reza
aslan and colin thompson it is produced
by safa samasa de yaz harris lane mick
dimaria hashem self and dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
what does your mom think of the book by
the way i don't know
has she yeah she's really proud of it
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah she's read it and
she read it before publication
um you know she's read it since then
she's very proud she still sort of
will say sometimes like
you know
like for her these are all just things
that happen you know and she's kind of
like yeah you know like lots of people
did that it wasn't that
you know not that remarkable but i think
that's sort of
for me and for other people to really
appreciate like how
extraordinary this story really is hey
thanks for watching you guys for more
fantastic videos just like the one that
you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you